I'm Brian Austin Green and I am here to
answer the Internet who is the one
president you would want to get
shit-faced way probably george w bush he
just he just seems like he'd be a good
one to get shit-faced with Barack would
have like too serious of a conversation
and I as much as I love him I feel like
that would sort of you'd lose the buzz a
little bit you know but george w george
w would you rather be stuck in Jumanji
or Jurassic Park that's that's a funny
question that's a good question I would
probably rather be stuck in Jumanji just
but I feel like you have more of a
chance that if you're living in Jurassic
Park
now think about living in Jurassic Park
with velociraptors with a t-rex what I
mean you can't you can't even be in the
visitor center because the the
velociraptors have figured out how to
open doors right so you're [ __ ] so at
least in Jumanji you can lock yourself
in and you sort of own [ __ ] so you go to
the grocery store you get stuff and
there's you know just avoid stamping
stampedes and lines you'll be good would
you rather have toes for fingers or
figures for toes son of a [ __ ] I'd
rather have fingers for toes then toes
for fingers just because you can't open
cans with your toes who wins in a fight
10 10 year olds or a hundred 100 year
olds 10 10 year olds would win I think
in a fight
it's a lot of bodies but there are a
hundred a hundred when you're a hundred
that's that's a harsh [ __ ] age 100m
that's you got to think that's I mean at
80 I like you wouldn't want to be 80 in
a fight let alone a hundred a
ten-year-old punches your kneecap you're
[ __ ] done that's just a lot of karate
chops and that hundred whittles down to
ten really fast if you could pick one
celebrity to be your wingman at the bar
who would you pick Seth Rogen would be
my wingman because he can handle himself
at a bar and he's he's funny and I could
just sit there and not say anything and
just be wasted and and he'll handle it
for me and he'll make me awesome if you
could live inside one TV show what would
you live in Cheers yeah thanks because
everybody there knows your name you get
to shoot one free throw for a million
but if you miss it you could never smoke
weed again is that a would I or wouldn't
I question yeah yeah I I
you could never smoke weed again that's
I mean I you know I'm 46 but that is a
long [ __ ] time to never smoke weed
again I'd go through that million much
faster than I will go through the back
half of my life with no weed so that's I
wouldn't take that shot the world either
loses all women are all sports which do
you choose
all sports yeah yeah I wouldn't lose my
wife and my kids for sports
no theme music meaning every time you
get hard this song plays what song would
you pick
oh geez
these questions are getting getting
tougher as we go again the theme song to
tears would you rather be bald by age 20
or 5 foot 3 or the full head of hair
ball by age 20 because I can always
shave my head and just make it a style
whereas being 5 foot 3 you're just
[ __ ] you can't you can wear lifts but
you only get to like 5 5 you get to
choose between a sum of money or world
peace how much does that sum of money
need to be in order for you not to
choose [ __ ] I don't damn it this isn't a
[ __ ] internet question see now we're
getting to your questions goddamnit I
think I just choose world peace alright
yeah yeah no it's because I have kids
man I don't I there's there's no amount
of money for a future that my kids are
in without world peace
she let me guess the you wrote this one
also you're building your dick from
scratch let's move on these dick
questions Jesus Christ yeah it's the
Internet right you're building your dick
from scratch you can make it as big as
you want but for every inch you add you
lose two years off your life how big do
you make it oh hey
well here's the thing I don't everyone
says they want to live a long life but I
honestly don't want to live past 80
because how great is your [ __ ]
quality of life at that at that point so
I would I would like to add maybe four
inches
to my dick and and just cut those for it
who needs those four years of life
anyway how will do you honestly want to
be
you